people ask me questions like what's on
the other side of a black hole which
doesn't make any sense when you realize
that black holes aren't holes they are
3D objects that were one stars that have
just been crushed down until they are so
so dense that the gravity is so strong
that nothing can escape from them
anymore not even light
what is your problem with the name black
holes
this is the thing this is something I've
spent my entire life like trying to
understand and yet I hate the name for
them I hate it so much I don't think
there's any other words in physics that
have caused more misconceptions
than black holes because they are
neither black nor are they holes black
holes and this is this is what bugs me
about them so you know people picture a
black hole as this physical hole in
space that stuff is like lost down you
know people ask me questions like what's
on the other side of a black hole which
doesn't make any sense when you realize
that black holes aren't holes they are
3D objects that were one stars that have
just been crushed down until they are so
so dense that the gravity is so strong
that nothing can escape it from them
anymore not even light they're almost
like prisons for light and I often say
that a better name for them was probably
Dark Star but even that's not not
perfect either so it I mean I'm sure a
lot of listeners could probably come up
with their own better names for them but
black hole especially is one that just
if I could go back and be like no let's
not call it that back to the sort of 60s
and 70s I would who was the guy that
called them black holes what was the
story yeah so it comes from a bit of a
harrowing part of History actually
um are you familiar with the Black Hole
of Calcutta no
so the Black Hole of Calcutta is a
prison cell
um in an Old Fort William in Calcutta in
India and
um there is this sort of tale from
history where British soldiers were
imprisoned in this prison cell which was
the size of three double beds
and there was about 70 soldiers
imprisoned overnight in this one very
cramped tight space and uh historians
sort of claims estimate you know that
around about 20 of them actually
survived that one single night after
being imprisoned in this such incredibly
cramped quarters
and there was a physicist called um
Robert Dickey in the 60s who was
studying what then were known as
gravitationally completely collapsed
objects or gccos which again is a term
I'm quite glad that didn't stick
um and him and his family used to say
that you know if something was lost in
their house oh it's gone to the Black
Hole of Calcutta
and so he started to use this phrase you
know in his academic talks as sort of
you know as like almost like brevity and
advertising value essentially was how it
was described by another physicists
called wheeler as well and uh
essentially he compared the crush of
Mata down to the the crush of these
soldiers in this prison cell as well in
the Black Hole of Calcutta and I think
when people hear about the Black Hole of
Calcutta there's lots of memorials still
in Calcutta in India today they think
that the prison got its name from the
astronomical objects but in fact it's
the other way around which I think
people don't realize what would happen
as you move around a black hole so I
think when people think about the black
hole they think about kind of a
two-dimensional object and if you were
to go side onto it that what's on the
other side you'd look at it from behind
what what is it like as you were if you
were to orbit around it is it a sphere
yeah it's just fear it's probably the
best way of putting it so I mean they
were one stars stars are spherical so
that's like saying you know what's on
the other side of the sun it's just
you're still looking at the sun you know
so more of the sun yeah so it's the same
with black holes and if you could sort
of orbit one very safely and see what
was going on what you would essentially
see is this sphere of Darkness where no
light was coming from it at all you were
receiving no information nothing and the
edge of that sphere is what we call the
Event Horizon so people might have heard
that term before this sort of point of
no return where nothing can escape the
black hole anymore because you can't
travel faster than the speed of light
if it's a
dark sphere what's your problem with the
word black then
so the other issue that I have with
black is that not all black holes are
dark in fact black holes are some of the
brightest objects in the entire universe
they light up like Christmas trees
um and that's because as gas comes into
a black hole and spirals around it
Beyond The Event Horizon where we can
still see that gas it gets accelerated
to huge speeds by the gravity of the
black hole and it gets hot and just like
you know if you stick an iron poker in a
forged fire right and the iron starts to
Glow because it gets hot this gas starts
to Glow in X-rays and UV light and even
visible light that you can see with your
own eyes as well
and so most black holes from you know
what we call Stellar Mass black holes
that are formed in Supernova when stars
die and we find them across our entire
galaxy you know there's probably
Millions to billions of black holes in
our entire galaxy right now that are
somewhere around like 10 times the mass
of the Sun something like that they all
light up so that you see them peppering
the night sky if you look at the night
sky with say an x-ray telescope they
light up and you see them there but not
only that supermassive black holes that
we think live in the center of every
single Galaxy every island of stars in
the universe is a trillion Stars there's
this supermassive black hole in the
middle that say a million to a billion
times the mass of the sun those things
can have so much gas around them that
they're so bright that they can outshine
all the stars in their galaxies to the
point where before we launched the
Hubble Space Telescope we detected the
X-ray light from these supermassive
black holes and didn't know what they
were
and we essentially dubbed them I said we
I wasn't around at this point but
essentially astronomers dubbed them at
quasi-stellar objects quasi-stellar
looks a bit like a star and that
eventually got shortened to quasar
and when the Hubble Space Telescope got
launched realized that these points of
light that we were seeing in the x-ray
they were actually entire galaxies but
it took the Hubble Space Telescope being
launched to realize there are entire
galaxies billions of light years away
that we weren't able to see the
Starlight from
but we could see the X-ray light from
the Quasar the growing supermassive
black hole in the very center of them
and yet we didn't know what they were at
the time when they were first spotted
do supermassive black holes are normal
black holes do they spin or is that
neutron stars that have a spin and do
some wild stuff
so neutron stars have a spin yes and
they do do wild stuff and if they have
magnetic fields they can send off these
big beams of radiation like a lighthouse
and I say a neutron star it's kind of
like the the baby sibling of a black
hole or for all the Pokemons
yeah not quite yeah but the Pokemon fans
out there a neutron star is a Pikachu to
a black holes where I chew right it's
the if I call is the next stage of
evolution for for a neutron star if you
add enough stuff to a neutron star
eventually becomes a black hole and so
yes black holes do spin because they
start life as either stars or neutron
stars if this star wasn't quite heavy
enough to become a black hole but that
neutron star could grow and grow until
it did become one and you really can't
shake off that spin that stars have so
the sun is spinning neutron stars are
spinning and black holes also remain
spinning as well and also as you add
more stuff to them and that comes in
swirling around them that adds more of
what we call angular momentum sort of
like rotational energy to make them spin
faster as well
um so a spinning black hole is
definitely something that that we see in
the universe when we observe them and
that was really clear and did you see
the Event Horizon telescope image of the
black hole in the center of our Milky
Way that was released back in May of
this year 2022. no is that a James Webb
thing or not no this is the Event
Horizon telescope so to jog your memory
it looks like a big orange donut
I feel like people go oh yeah the Big
Orange donut image when I say this and
that image was was really quite blurred
and the reason it was blurred was
because you know we were taking an image
for a couple of hours trying to collect
as much light as possible you know
imagine sort of like a night mode shot
on your phone you do 10 seconds right to
let in all the light this was a few
hours and in that time the black hole
had been spinning and so the material
around it that you were capturing the
image of was moving and so you end up
with a slightly a slightly blurred
orange donut image and that was one of
the questions I got when that image came
out was why is it blurred like surely we
should be able to get a nice crisp
picture exactly yeah so you have the
opportunity there's multiple ways that a
black hole could form you have a large
star that collapses in on itself when
it's no longer got the energy to
continue to support or to stop Gravity
from pushing it in but another one is a
neutron star which is pretty big star
condenses down but then accumulates more
matter over time time just as when the
formations of planets and stars
originally happened it's just gravity is
bringing stuff in that must be a very
interesting way to form a black hole
because it's that there has to be a
point at which
is it it's the straw that broke the
camel's back it's the piece of matter
that created the black hole from the
neutron star that seems like quite a
unique way to create one
exactly that yeah it's so that limit
that you were just talking about is
called the Tolman Oppenheimer volkov
limit so Oppenheimer might be a name
that some people recognize from the
Manhattan Project nuclear bombs the
reason he was brought onto that project
was because he was a nuclear physicist
studying neutrons and neutron stars
um and so that limit is actually
incredibly informative if you can
measure what that is like what's the
maximum mass of a neutron star or the
minimum mass of a black hole he will
formed in that way
um and there's loads of different ways
you can get it out you can survey the
neutron star population and say let's
see if we can observe all the neutron
stars how big are they how massive the
sort of edge of that distribution will
tell us but also we've recently started
detecting what's known as gravitational
waves
um which are literal ripples in space
itself from this cataclysmic merger of
say two neutron stars that can also form
a black hole and again that kind of a
limit of when do you cross over that
point when have you added too much
matter in the straw that's broken the
camel's back to make it a Black Horn we
think that's around
three ish times the mass of the Sun but
drilling that down to is it 3.2 is it
3.1 is it 3.115 you know getting it that
is quite difficult
um and you can get it in terms of like
modeling what neutrons do and how
neutrons behave and literally how can
they be arranged in this almost perfect
Crystal like a neutron star is
essentially this perfect Crystal of
neutrons arranged as tightly as they can
go you know the physics of our
understanding of neutrons that we can
actually look at in the lab at how they
behave we can then work out okay
mathematically what would be the limit
and is that model right or is there some
bit of physics that we've forgotten here
that we get from our observations
what is the form of matter that's in a
black hole then if a neutron star is
neutrons pushed together in this perfect
form of a crystal which is as dense as
we could possibly imagine theoretically
as we could
what would that can't be as dense as it
could be because there's something
denser than that and that's a black hole
exactly and unfortunately that's one of
those questions that we don't know and
under the laws of physics is we
understand them we will probably never
know that's one of those frustrating
things as a scientist like we're taught
to ask so many questions and it's like
the one thing that we almost can't
answer so inside that event horizon
where it's it's sort of that that shroud
that you're no longer receiving any
light so there's no information so you
have no idea what's going on inside that
sphere of Darkness essentially there
could be some exotic form of matter that
we don't know that exists yet because we
could never recreate that on Earth in a
lab because we don't have the ability to
to make anything that dense but also
you'd never be able to observe it
because you could never get light from
it because it would be this form of
matter that was so dense as to create
this event horizon in a black hole or it
could be that there is no form of matter
that can resist collapsing down
completely and you end up with how we
describe a black hole mathematically
which is a singularity so that might be
a phrase that people have heard of
before essentially means all your matter
is compressed into an infinitely dense
infinitesimally small Point that's
undefinable in space in terms of how
strong the gravity is there
mathematically what happens is you end
up trying to divide by zero
which I think if you remember the film
mean girls with Lindsay Lohan the answer
to that is the limit does not exist
um so it's something that you can't do
mathematically is divide by zero you end
up essentially going to Infinity if
you're trying to divide by zero and so
that's how we describe them
mathematically but whether that's
actually truly the physics of what's
going on inside that shroud of darkness
in the event horizon we don't know
I would love to know
but we don't
given the fact that there are varying
sizes from black hole to supermassive
black hole it would suggest that that it
it can't be uh uniform that that the
variation in the size of the black holes
is due to something that's going on so
the infinitesimally small might be
slightly less infinitesimally small and
bigger black holes I don't know no not
necessarily so even if a black hole is
10 times the mass of the Sun or 10
million times the mass of the Sun the
math still describes them as this
singularity
where everything 10 Mark times masterton
or 10 million times the masses on is
compressed into this infinitesimally
small point but again that's the maths
it's not necessarily an observation that
we've made in terms of astronomy or
astrophysics and I am an observer I use
telescopes so really that's that's what
I'm always going to want but under the
laws of physics we understand them we're
probably never going to be able to
observe that so we do have to fall back
on the maths necessarily of how we
describe them but it's interesting you
you say like you have this obviously
distribution of these masses because
we do see this sort of distribution of
what I call normal black holes you
piddly ones that sit in the Galaxy you
know formed from the death of stars ten
times the Master's done up to say say
100 or so times to mass the Sun
and then supermassive black holes which
go from a million up to tens of billion
times the mass of the sun
and we just have this dearth of things
in the middle
we don't we've never found anything
between 100 to a million or so times the
mass of the Sun they're called
intermediate Mass black holes and
they're considered almost like the
missing piece of the puzzle
like sort of like the the missing like
Gap almost because if you think about
well how did supermassive black holes
become so supermassive if the only
process we know to create a black hole
comes from a supernova which forms
something like you know that star Mass
like 10 times to match the sun you've
got to then grow that
to become supermassive so you'd think if
these black holes were growing all the
time to become supermasses you'd see
something in the middle but we don't
so it's a very interesting problem in
astrophysics about why we don't see
things of that mass has all the growth
already happened of supermassive black
holes yet but then why don't we see them
in the early universe as well and that's
one question we're hoping maybe James
the James Webb Space Telescope will be
able to help answer as well as it looks
back further and further to fainter
things at greater distance which are
also the light has taken longer to get
to us so we're seeing the universe as it
was billions of years ago
your best models at the moment suggest
that there is a supermassive black hole
at the center of
every Galaxy are there any galaxies that
don't have supermassive black holes in
the middle
yeah so the working hypothesis is that
every single one does there are a few
candidates where
there is speculation about whether there
might not be and that is usually in the
case of what we call dwarf galaxies so
for those in who've been to the Southern
Hemisphere or who live in the southern
hemisphere you'll know what I'm talking
about when I say the large magellanic
Cloud which is a little dwarf galaxy to
the Milky Way that's in orbit around us
and you can see it from the southern
hemisphere is this little patch on the
sky of stars that are much denser and
there's sort of gas around it if you
crack up a camera or a camera phone or
something like that you can snap it with
um and something like that there's still
debate about okay well maybe do they
have these intermediate Mass black holes
in the center because we know that
Galaxy mass and black hole Mass are
correlated so if they're smaller in size
and mass they should have smaller black
holes so perhaps maybe that's something
where we'll find them as well but there
are some candidates where we've observe
the Galaxy and the orbit of the Stars
suggests there is nothing in the center
in which case well
why and how how did they almost Escape
uh getting a supermassive black hole and
if if that can happen then how did all
the other galaxies that we see having
supermassive black holes in the center
end up with one
there's lots of different questions and
I think people are surprised when we say
there is actually that much that we
don't know still but black hole studies
in supervised black hole studies
especially is still such a young science
that's only been going for probably
about 20 years or so
I mean back in the 90s black holes were
still called massive dark objects
because we didn't quite know what they
were at least supermassive black holes
were
and it was only sort of with the
observations of the center of the Milky
Way and the Stars orbiting around the
very very center that we were looked at
with the the kex based telescopes on
Mauna Kea in Hawaii
they look in the infrared so they can
sort of peer through the dust that's
towards the center of the Milky Way and
see the actual positions of the stars
and track them over like 15 years one of
these Stars has made a whole orbit in
that time in just in just about 12 years
I think and from that you can then work
out well how fast they're orbiting
the thing in the middle you can work out
okay how big is this thing in the middle
and you work out that it's about four
million times the mass of the Sun in an
area smaller than the solar system
and for a while people were like maybe
it's a swarm of black holes because
these smaller black holes were known
they've been seen as these little x-ray
Points of Light all over the sky but
supermassive black holes weren't thought
to be real necessarily so people
considered the idea of a swarm of black
holes which I almost wish was real I
just thought that this sort of like
beehive of black holes almost just
swarming around but in fact that would
be really unstable you'd have things
sort of like slingshotting around each
other and being pinged out all the time
and so instead this idea of yeah a
supermassive black hole and since you've
finally been able to get a picture of
one with the Event Horizon telescope as
well it's confirmed the idea that it is
one supermassive black hole
supermassive black holes in the middle
of almost all galaxies
all of the galaxies are around the point
in the Middle where the black hole is
does that mean that the black hole is
what's holding the Galaxy together does
the or is it the fact that black holes
end up at the center of galaxies and the
rest of the Gravity from that matter
just holds itself together
yes that's a really big question that we
have in astrophysics like what comes
first the Galaxy or the black hole it's
kind of like the astrophysics chicken or
the egg essentially like do you have a
galaxy of stars one goes Supernova
become a black hole
that happens distinct to the middle and
the whole thing forms around it or do
you have like a cloud of gas in the
early universe that just directly
collapse into a black hole and then
Stars sort of shepherded and form around
that that's also one of the questions
we're hoping that James face telescope
will answer because it's you know been
designed to look back to the first stars
and first galaxies forming but that idea
of taking a black hole out of the center
of the Galaxy with the Galaxy fly apart
because if you did the same thing in the
solar system if you took the Sun out of
the center of the solar system the sun
is
99.99 of all the mass in the solar
system take it out and all the planets
would just fly off the whole thing would
completely disperse and fall apart
in a galaxy the black hole is not even
one percent of the entire mass of the
Galaxy the Galaxy always outweighs the
supermassive black hole in the center
and so if you removed it nothing would
actually happen to the Galaxy it would
actually hold itself together under
what's known as self gravity
and when you actually stop to think
about this this is the reason we have a
galaxy of stars in the first place and
not just a big disc of gas just slowly
fueling the black hole over you know
billions of years because essentially
what it means is that the gravity
that is in this region of space that
we're in in terms of the Sun the gravity
is sort of stronger like holding the
Earth around the Sun than it is the
gravity pulling towards the black hole
in the center or even holding the sun
together in the first place
and so that self gravity of the galaxies
is enough to to stop everything from
falling into the black hole and it's why
I tell people like you don't need to
worry right everything just orbits black
holes and will happily continue to do
that in the same way that the Earth will
happily orbit the sun like as long as
you don't panic you know at night that
the Earth is going to fall into the sun
I mean you don't need to panic about
falling into a black hole either what is
the biggest black hole that's been found
so far
so it's got a rather uh uninspiring name
the biggest black hole found it's called
ton618
you know recommendations for what we can
rename it Are Much appreciated
um and the supermassive black hole at
the center of that Galaxy is close to 70
billion times the mass of the sun
which we basically had to give it a new
name it had to become Ultra massive
black hole at that point because that is
just right on the edge of you know what
we think is possible and actually
reaching the point that we think might
be the maximum mass that a black hole
can grow to
tall why would there be a mess
yeah so it's because of this idea of
self-gravity again if you've got this
disc of gas spiraling around the black
hole then at some point as the as the
black hole grows you sort of push out
what's called the the innermost stable
circular orbit
and so that's essentially the last point
that you can get something orbiting
safely before it you know it can't hold
itself off and it will fall into the
black hole and it will spiral in and
essentially what happens is that that
moves so far beyond the Event Horizon
that you can get a disc of gas around
the black hole and it will never
fall into the black hole would that mean
that you would end up with a band of no
man's land in between the material and
the black hole exactly yeah you would
have this no man's land where if
something did happen to fall into there
like say there was a you know a passing
gas cloud or you know you chucked an
asteroid in there or something like that
then if it hit no man's land yes it
would fall into the black hole or if it
merged with another black hole that came
in then it could grow but the usual way
that black holes grow is is by what we
call accretion which is from this gas
that's spiraling around the black hole
and essentially what you've got to do is
you've got to remove energy from that
gas so if you think about it in terms of
like molecules with energy they're all
pinging around and they've got enough
energy to keep them on an orbit but if
they collide with another molecule it's
like a game of pool or snooker you know
you hit the cue ball into another ball
and the cue ball stops and the other one
goes flying so if that kind of collision
happens whether where one of these
molecules stops all of a sudden that
that disrupts that orbit and it can fall
in because that pull of gravity from the
black hole then pull it in but if you've
got a case where you've got this no
man's land in the Middle where even if
it lost enough energy it still wouldn't
fall into the black hole
because it's far enough away that it
could always still Escape even if it had
you know lost a lot of energy in a
collision or something like that which
is amazing to think of that I think we
could be living through this era of
really or was it reaching this Epoch of
the the maximum Mass black holes could
could grow to
in the universe with finding this ton618
uh super massive black oh sorry Ultra
massive black hole at the center of this
galaxy I mean it kind of gives me
goosebumps like I don't know there to be
excited or disappointed that we're
living through the era that black holes
could be reaching their maximum why is
ic1101 not the universe which has got
the biggest black hole at the center of
it given that it's the biggest
Galaxy that we found
so
because that is the
isolation there so if you put Galaxy
mass and you plot Black Hole Mass the
two are correlated but it's not a
perfect correlation there's always some
scatter that depends on what's happened
in the universe's history
in terms of to that galaxy has it merged
with other galaxies in which case it's
probably merged its supermassive black
hole in the center was there some
interaction in the Galaxy that sort of
pulled on all the gas and stars in it
that happened to send gas tumbling
towards the center
that kind of thing every galaxy has an
individual history so perhaps for that
one
you know maybe it's merged a lot of
times but the black holes haven't merged
yet so maybe we're recording more mass
but in in terms of stars but we're not
recording in the supermassive black hole
yet maybe in ton618 it just got really
lucky in terms of the Galaxy managed to
feed it by itself to grow it that big
even if the Galaxy didn't get any bigger
as well so there's all sorts of
different reasons that's just very
complex histories you know these things
have had 13.8 billion years to evolve
right there's a lot that can happen in
that time
you've just mentioned there that two
black holes could meet two supermassive
black holes could meet
what happens then what what's that event
like
we don't know we've never observed an
event like that so we do have uh the
ligo experiment and the Virgo experiment
on Earth right now that are detecting
gravitational waves from you know the
the Stellar Mass black holes that form
from Supernova those are in our own
Galaxy that emerging together so I mean
by gravitational wave if we picture
um sort of gravity like how Einstein did
where he said you know if you have
massive curved space so imagine taking
like a football chucking it on the
center of a trampoline and then you know
like rolling like a ping pong ball
around it that would be sort of the
equivalent of what mass does to space
and if you imagine taking that football
and having two footballs and bouncing
them on that trampoline you'd imagine
the trampoline is is obviously under a
lot of stress and so when two black
holes are coming together and merging
they're spiraling around each other at
incredible speeds and curving and
uncurving space as they go past to
extreme amounts and so they send ripples
out into space when this happens and the
biggest of those ripples happens when
they finally come together and merge and
we actually are able to detect that here
on the ground on Earth we literally
watch the distance between two mirrors
where you've got a laser firing back and
forth measuring the distance between
them very very accurately change by you
know less than the width of an atom we
see that and we can detect that okay
well something just merged in the
universe over there
with a supermassive black hole
it's a different frequency of wave that
you get
and so what we have to do is we have to
build bigger and bigger detectors that
distance between the two mirrors has to
increase for us to be able to detect
that to the point where you would need
it bigger than the entire Earth
which is insane right but there is a
plan to do that
there is a plan it's called the Lisa
Observatory and we're hoping to maybe
launch it in sort of the 2030s 2040s
probably more likely and it would
literally be these three sort of uh
spacecraft in space in a triangle that
would sort of Trail the Earth in its
orbit kept in one of these what's known
as sort of a gravitationally stable
point just like what the James Webb
Space telescope's currently at as well
um and they would stay there and they
would essentially have this the system
of firing a laser back and forth to
detect the distance between the two
mirrors and if it changes you know a
gravitational wave has gone past so
hopefully I can answer your question
maybe in 2040 or so we can say this is
what happens when two supermassive black
holes merge but you can imagine it's
probably a very
cataclysmic event when it does happen
I read the five ages or the five stages
of the universe which was a book
recommended to me ages ago now to get it
on self print on Amazon anyway it it
talks a lot about the different stages
that the universe will go through and
that a period of just black holes will
take up an awful lot of the future of
the universe and then very very slowly
due to
Hawking radiation yeah
they will evaporate over time
um how long why is it that black holes
lose their Mass how long does it take
while talking radiation
I mean you've really gone for literally
the most difficult questions we could
ever ask right so obviously this this
um sort of situation that you would have
for the end of the universe of being
black holes and them having enough time
to evaporate means that the universe is
probably just going to keep expanding
forever or reaches a happy medium and
stops the other option is that it starts
to contract again we still don't know
quite know which one of those is
actually going to happen we have some
sort of ways of testing which one that
would be but
sort of on the fence still
um but if it was to expand forever and
yes everything eventually might become
part of a black hole as Stars start to
die off and slowly accrete stuff around
them if everything there was a black
hole they could indeed evaporate but it
would take I mean a supermassive black
hole would probably be like a Google
number of years right 10 to the power of
a hundred which is an incredibly large
number and Hawking radiation is is a
strange thing that Hawking worked on
because he was obsessed with this idea
of entropy
I don't know if you've ever heard this
came in physics before and essentially
there's a law of physics that says
entropy cannot decrease an entropy is
almost like a measure of the disorder of
the universe but really I mean what it
means is that the most likely thing
that's going to happen is going to
happen so like if I had a nice warm mug
of tea in front of me right now that's a
nice ordered system because all of the
heat is in the tea and the air around it
is cooler but we know what will happen
is that the heat will disperse and it
will warm the air around it and
everything will get more disordered
essentially rather than having a hot
here and cold here will all be sort of
mixed about
and so how can we obsessed with this
idea of this was a law of physics that
had been known for a very long time for
hundreds of years it was a law of
thermodynamics as it's called and black
holes seemed to break this
because if you're trapping matter and
energy and light in a black hole
you are removing disorder from the
universe and making it more ordered
almost like someone organizing things
something like this or lives here and
this all lives here you're making
something so much more ordered and so he
was obsessed with this idea in trying to
reconcile
the theory around black holes and
thermodynamics and eventually he he sort
of came up with a very theoretical
description that goes into very much of
the quantum mechanics and what's going
on in terms of like vacuum energy of the
universe but essentially if you form a
black hole you disrupt some of the
Quantum signatures that are going
through space so these are sort of very
tiny sort of the quantum realm we're
talking about the physics of the very
very small sort of particles what energy
to space itself actually has
so by creating a black hole you disrupt
that and from the surface you then could
have some of that disrupted energy
escaping
as Hawking radiation
and so this would mean that actually you
are putting disorder back into the
universe in that respect
the thing is it's incredibly unlikely
that that happens the same with anything
in quantum mechanics right there is a
almost this very strange probabilistic
aspect to it that says you know at the
edge of the table that's in front of me
right now there is a very vanishingly
small probability that that edge of that
table is not there because the atoms
that make it up could be halfway across
the universe
uh in quantum mechanics that is true
that is a true statement and so
Hawking radiation while the maths checks
out
the time it would take for that to
happen is ridiculously long even what we
call a primordial black hole that might
have formed in the early universe that
might be you know less than the mass of
the Earth even
that still wouldn't have had enough time
to evaporate by now in 13.8 billion
years and put its energy back out into
space
um and it's never something we've ever
observed either we should be able to
observe it it would be given off in
what's known as gamma rays some of the
highest energy form of light and we do
have gamma-ray telescopes looking at the
sky like Supernova and things like this
give off gamma rays but we've never
spotted anything that looks like Hawking
radiation before and like I said before
I use telescopes I'm an observer I like
to have the observational evidence
before you know sort of saying this is a
real thing so hulking radiation is still
a hypothetical
concept
I learned a little while ago something
interesting about the speed of light so
nothing can go faster than the speed of
light is something that everybody hears
about
I heard correct me if I'm wrong that
there is a speed limit in the universe
and that the speed of light happens to
go at that speed limit not that the
upper bound of the speed that the
Universe moves at at its maximum
velocity is determined by light
exactly exactly that's correct yeah it
just so happens to be that light moves
at the the speed limit of what we have
in physics
um and it comes from I mean Einstein's
theory of general relativity and special
relativity you know marries this
beautifully and shows why this is the
case but essentially as you get closer
to the speed of light things start to
act very differently than what they do
you know here unlike Earth in what we
call non-relativistic speeds normal
everyday speeds like if you are running
somewhere you're jogging Pace maybe you
start to put more energy in
you increase the speed that you jog at
and that's sort of you know the same
choose for a car right you push the
accelerator you burn more fuel you put
more energy and you start to go faster
as you approach the speed of light you
put more energy in and all of a sudden
it doesn't start increasing your
velocity it starts to increase your
momentum instead and your momentum
is sort of like how difficult it is to
stop you moving so we have momentum on
the ground here as well and we calculate
that as mass times velocity
but if it's not the velocity that
increases then but the momentum still
increases it means your mass increases
so as you travel past the speed of light
you you put more energy in you don't get
any faster instead your mass just keeps
going up and up and up and up and up to
infinity and so there's almost again
this limit does not exist right you get
this this limit where nothing can go
faster than the speed of light
it just gets heavier just gets heavier
yeah that's interesting okay what is the
Schwarz child radius
this watch child radius is the Event
Horizon
essentially so that that sphere around
the black hole where you don't get any
information from and Schwarz child was I
mean an incredible physicist so
I mean Einstein power its theory of
general relativity smack bang in the
middle of World War One in 1916. and
schwartzshou was on the uh one of the
fronts uh one of the German fronts I
think was the Eastern front and he
shouldn't have been there he volunteered
essentially he was too old at the time
but he was like no I'll still volunteer
despite having
a lot of medical problems as well
and he unfortunately died about a year
or so after Einstein put out his theory
of general relativity
in that time though he was fighting on
the Eastern front and wrote three maybe
four physics papers
on Einstein's theory general relativity
wrote a lot of letters back and forth
that Einstein being like I found this
solution in the trenches in the trenches
yeah
and unfortunately then and literally
after that you know passed away very
young I think in its early 40s
and essentially what he
derived was this idea of what happens if
your mass is all sort of contained in
this sort of sphere
and he was sort of doing it in terms of
like a star right it was sort of if you
have a spherical object and you work in
what's called
um you know spherical coordinates so you
work in instead of x y z so up down
forward back left right you work in sort
of uh how big is your circle how far
around your circle are you and have a
round the other side of the circle are
you essentially and he worked out for
those kind of coordinates which Einstein
hadn't done
and if you look at that solution you get
this what we call a singularity where
essentially R equals zero the very
middle you cannot Define the strength of
gravity at that point and it's what's
been come to known as The Singularity
but there's another Singularity that
occurs which is at the schwartzell
radius which depends on how heavy the
thing is
which for a normal star the scratch out
radius is well in with that inside the
star it's nothing to worry about you
know whatever
because it's not a real Singularity like
the one in the middle it just comes
about because of the fact that you work
in you know these spherical coordinates
instead but what it defines is that what
people didn't realize at the time
because this was back in you know the
the 1910s right and black holes weren't
really even theoretical Curiosities
until the 50s and 60s
um what people realized eventually was
that that schwartzell radius was the
event horizon that point of no return
where you can't literally see anything
over the horizon anymore
is it not a paradox a little bit that
nothing can move faster than the speed
of light but that something can have
enough gravitational pull to be stronger
than the speed of light
I don't think it's a paradox necessarily
no because the Paradox would suggest
that there is something broken in there
but it would just suggest that there's
this law of physics that you know says
nothing can escape from it if if you
have to be traveling faster than that
speed limit of the Universe I think it's
a paradox necessarily I just think it's
a really interesting Quirk of nature yes
I guess it depends on how you see
the movement of light versus the effect
of gravity because I got it in my head
that it's kind of like somebody running
on a treadmill you know and it's like in
order for something to not be able to go
that way something has to go in the
opposite direction at quicker than that
speed but no not necessarily it seems
that that's not the way that it works
you know with regards to gravity if you
were I'm pretty sure that this is a
common thought experiment if the sun was
to disappear like that how long would it
be before the gravity effect hit Earth
eight minutes the same is like right
okay exact speed of light as well yes
exactly and that's something Einstein's
theory general relativity explained as
well and it's the speed that say those
gravity waves that we were talking about
before in terms of these ligo
experiments that detect gravitational
waves that's the speed they also travel
at so it's very interesting that we
didn't know that for sure
it was a prediction of Einstein's
general relativity but when uh ligo
detected the merger of two neutron stars
which obviously we can see still because
they're not quite heavy enough yet to
trap light there was both a
gravitational wave and a burst of light
from it which was astronomy's worst kept
secret at the time when it happened a
few years ago because literally every
telescope in the world dropped what they
took and moved to look at this thing to
record it as soon as they'd had the
alert that this had happened to the
point where you know we have Twitter
Bots these days as well that's like the
Hubble Space Telescope is now looking at
you know such and such a star for this
person and this happened and we were
like that person works on neutron star
collisions and like the next day it was
like for such a such a person that
person works on ligo you know
immediately like there was all these
cogs turning up everyone knew what was
going on
um and obviously you know you have
everyone has mates at telescopes and
stuff So eventually sort of word crept
around that that's what happened so we
all knew it was coming to know that you
know have it confirmed or not whether uh
gravity traveled at sort of the same
speed as light did I like the idea of a
VIP guest list for working out what's
going on in the universe and if you're
on the right if you're in the what right
WhatsApp chat then you get to find out
when cool stuff's gonna happen before
everybody else yeah or if you just
happen to be like scheduled to use that
telescope that night then you know doing
your own sort of stuff and then someone
comes in and goes no sorry we just need
an hour to look at this thing we're busy
this evening we've got to focus it
somewhere else so yeah
you've said earlier on that there is
potentially an upper bound that black
holes could potentially become full
does that does that mean that the event
horizon creeps out then does the Event
Horizon become bigger as a black hole
increases in size yeah um so the event
horizon or the smart Shard radius is
related directly to the mass of the
black hole
so when we say the size of the black
hole we mean the size across we mean
like the the diameter almost of the
Event Horizon when we're talking about
the mass we're talking about how heavy
is it and the two are directly related
and basically what the schwartzell
radius is is an equation to tell you how
big is that diameter of the Event
Horizon given how big your black hole is
and it's basically just depends on how
fast is the speed of light how strong is
gravity boom there's your radius for
when light can't escape from it anymore
and it's a really simple equation
and I I just I mean I would encourage
anyone to Google schwartshad radius
right now and put your own weight in
there
and you can work out what what size of a
black hole you would be I I've done it
many a time and it's quite fun that
you're like I am not Point not not like
many many zeros one meter uh size black
hole if I could squish myself down into
a black hole
do black holes ever form without a
neutron star is it possible that
sufficient material would be able to
come together or if it did that would it
form a star that would then
live a life that would then collapse in
on itself that would then become a black
hole
it just all depends on how big the star
is that's lived before so something like
the sun won't make a black hole it will
make what's called a white dwarf which
is again the baby sibling to a neutron
star something heavier than the sun
let's say three times to ten times the
mass of the sun will become a neutron
star at the end of the life it'll go
supernova throw out all the outer layers
so the majority of the mass say like
seven or eight times the mass the sun
just gets swirled out back into space
and that's how we end up with these
beautiful nebula that we see these big
round nebula and at the middle you'll
leave behind the core
and if it's three to ten times the
master Sun that's the star beforehand it
will be it will be a neutron star that
core
but if the star is heavier than say 10
times the mass of the Sun up to let's
say 100 200 times the massive Sun that
same process will happen in terms of you
have the Supernova that throws since you
get this like rebound of all the outer
layers that bounce back off because
they're very light hydrogen gas with a
very heavy core and the core is what
collapses down then into the black hole
there are some Stars
that we have seen there one day and gone
the next
and have speculated whether that those
stars have just skipped Supernova
entirely and directly collapsed down
into a black hole isn't that nice event
exactly yeah exactly that so that's sort
of what you end what you end up with you
end up with this sort of Trifecta of the
graveyard of stars basically white dwarf
neutron star black hole and it all
depends how big the star was in the
first place essentially but as we said
before you can add Mass to your neutron
star you can keep adding stuff to it and
it could become a black hole and we
actually see this happening because the
majority of stars are actually not alone
like the sun they're going to be in
binary pairs especially heavier Stars
the heavier stars form where there's
more gas so with more gas you're going
to get more stars and they end up in
these not just binary systems tertiary
quadrine whatever the word is to
describe it where you have three four
five up to seven or eight stars all
orbiting each other in this intricate
pattern so you can imagine if one of
them goes Supernova and becomes a black
hole
which also the biggest stars die first
they burn through their fuel quickest
because they have to burn more fuel to
resist the larger Crush of gravity
because they're so big and so you have
all these other stars with a black hole
then and obviously the black hole can
then start to steal Material off other
stars
same can happen if you've got a neutron
star it can pull Material off other
stars and use it to grow
and the color black hole same is true
for a white dwarf it can pull Material
off other stars and use it to grow until
it becomes a neutron star and when that
happens when a white dwarf reaches that
upper limit as well of its mass we have
another type of supernova a supernova
called a type 1A and they always go off
at the exact same brightness across the
entire universe because it's this limit
to how big a white dwarf can be before
it becomes a neutron star of course yes
and you might have heard of these things
called standard these are standard
candles which are these things that we
can use to calculate distances because
if they're always the same brightness
from how bright they appear we can work
out how far away they are and then then
say okay this Galaxy's at this distance
we now know and it's got this red shift
this stretching of its light due to the
expansion of space and then we can work
out okay well how fast is Space
expanding rewind time how long has it
been expanding for
and you work out hold the age of the
universe is
it seems like everything
astronomically is moving toward black
holes in that case
so yeah in the fact that
adding more mass eventually
everything will become a black hole and
as you said before if Stars continue to
die and you get left behind with all of
these things and everything starts to
merge and come together over time then
yeah you would end up with a black hole
it's almost like the inevitable end to
all matter unless you've got something
resisting that Crush of gravity down and
the expansion of the universe could be
one of those things right that's
literally moving Mata away from or that
likes moving galaxies at least away from
other things so it's obviously galaxies
are held together by their local gravity
but between galaxies sometimes the pull
of gravity is strong enough that it will
bring two of them together like the
Milky Way and Andromeda will merge in
say two billion years but in other cases
the expansion means that galaxies are a
majority of case most galaxies are
getting further apart
what's the best image that we've got of
a black hole
it's definitely the Event Horizon
telescope images
um in terms of we have this one from the
Galaxy Messier 87 that was the first one
was that was released this giant orange
donut and then we had our own
supermassive black hole in the center of
the Milky Way released in May this year
and they are incredible to look at
because I mean I had I mean this is what
got me into space in the first place but
it's eight years old I remember I got
this book for a birthday or Christmas or
something and it was just a fact file
about all the things in space so it went
through all the solar system objects you
know and they had all the beautiful
images from say The Voyage of crafts in
the 70s and 80s or even the Hubble Space
Telescope and then you got onto stars
and galaxies and black holes and I
remember the black hole page I was
almost annoyed at because on every other
page of this beautiful image from a
telescope and on the black hole page it
was like artists impression
and I sort of resigned myself at an
early age to be like yeah I will never
get an image of a black hole because you
know they're they're black and there's
nothing to see and whatever and as I got
further into my sort of
education doing an undergrad degree in
astrophysics and my PhD and everything I
realized actually no it could be a
possibility if we could take an image of
that gas swirling around the black hole
and capture that darkness in the middle
and that's essentially what they did and
when when I saw that image for the first
time I remember getting just Goosebumps
because I never thought that that could
ever you know be the case that we could
actually see that for ourselves and what
I think so powerful about that image
you know you've got the Blackness of
empty space around the outside then
you've got this incredibly hot gas
plasma that's swirling around the black
hole bright orange it's colored you know
so that humans can sort of detect where
it's brighter and fainter and then
you've got the blackness in the middle
and you think about the black on the
outside is nothingness
and the black on the inside is
everything
comparing the the sort of the two black
is is is insane when you when you think
about how different and yet similar
similar color but so different in
it in nature almost as well of what
those two things are and uh I mean I get
I get goosebumps every time I see it
when I remember that and really think
about it stop and think about it
James Webb Telescope recently went up
some incredibly interesting and or
inspiring images coming from that what's
next as one of the
experimentalist observerists that's not
just theoretically writing this stuff
down
James Webb's been planned for what
decades now three decades something like
that maybe even more yeah it was
originally five years I think it's now
20 years is the sort of Promise time but
could be longer if it doesn't need to
use as much fuel essentially so what is
next in terms of
telescopes or we've already mentioned
about this a gravitationally stable
Triad of mirrors that are going to
follow follow the universe around like a
little tail
um yeah what else is there
so after the James of Space Telescope
there's so many more telescopes coming
and so many things to get excited for
one I'm particularly excited for because
in my research field it's really going
to have such a huge impact is something
called the extremely large telescope the
elt that is actually its name um it is
extremely large it's 30 meters across
so James Webb we think of that being
very large 6.5 meters across so maybe a
you know a two-story house but with 30
meter mirror to collect the light as
much light as it can and focus it down
is it I mean it's just incredible to
think of how big that would be you know
sort of mansion-sized telescope almost
and that's going to give us better
resolution in the Hubble Space Telescope
but from the ground not from space where
you're not looking through atmosphere
that distorts everything
um and so that's going to be an
incredible thing because not only will
that telescope be able to take say a
single image of say a Galaxy
what it will do is to almost like Mosaic
a Galaxy up
into little segments and observe all of
those simultaneously but not just take
an image from each one of those segments
it will split the light through a prism
into its rainbow into its spectrum of
light and make a trace of how much light
of every color you're receiving and
that's critically important because
elements in the universe give off
specific colors like a fingerprint and
so we know how much hydrogen or oxygen
or nitrogen there exists in a galaxy and
and how that relates to how many stars
are forming or how many stars are dying
at that period at that that time
and you can do it in every single little
segment of that Galaxy which the amount
of detail we're going to have from that
the kind of resolution we're going to
have in terms of you know Hubble
resolution but from the ground and being
able to do this this piecing together is
something I'm really excited for
um and then you've also got massive
radio telescopes being built as well
there's something called the square
kilometer array being built the one in
South Africa and one in Australia at the
elt that I just talked about in Chile in
the Atacama Desert but these uh square
kilometer a really is what it says on
the tin it's an array of radio antennae
spread across a square kilometer
and you combine them so that they become
one telescope that is a square kilometer
so not like 30 meters across but a
square kilometer across because as you
get to longer and longer wavelengths of
light so the wavelength being sort of
the distance between the peaks of light
with radio light for example which is
the light we used to communicate you
know we send radio signals we send TV
signals using and sort of encoded on
radio light because the wavelengths are
meters tens of meters long and we can
detect that light from space as well and
it tells usually where there's like
magnetic fields and stuff like that in
space and and also hydrogen gas as well
it also has this resonance in radio
light too so this fact that you know as
you get to larger longer wavelengths of
light you need a larger telescope to
detect it this is why we have to keep
going to these square kilometers but it
also means your resolution is incredible
as well that as in the thing the size of
the thing you can actually resolve on
the sky just gets smaller and smaller
the bigger your telescope gets as well
so the I mean the resolution we're going
to have with a telescope that is a
square kilometer across
it's gonna be insane
Dr Becky smethis ladies and gentlemen if
people want to keep up to date with the
stuff that you do and everything online
why should they go
uh so I'm on YouTube uh Dr Becky is the
channel name and I chat about basically
what we've been chatting about now um
sort of like the questions that you're
not able to Google because all you're
going to get back is you know just
research papers that are written from
you know by my colleagues for by you
know my colleagues in the general public
just don't have a hope of you know going
through all of that language and jargon
that we use so it's sort of like I act
as a translator if you will on the
channel we chat about what's new in
space news and things like that
um but also you know Twitter Instagram
and uh from my books as well Becky I
appreciate you thank you what's
happening people thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that episode
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
[Music]